[Music]
foreign
people I'm Dave Rubin and via your
computer we are live on the internet
whatever that is this is the Reuben
report and it is Friday which means it's
time for another Friday Roundtable
Extravaganza we've got a Florida Bonanza
for you joining me is the senior editor
at Newsweek and host of the Josh Hammer
show Josh hammer and New York Post and
Fox News columnist Carol Marco it's Josh
Carroll my Florida friends welcome back
to the Reuben report
great to see you babe it's always a
career risk joining you but I'm happy to
risk it for you
let's see if we can blow up both of your
careers today actually before we start
since this is a fla Florida Power Hour
and everyone knows Carol and I moved
basically I think within two days of
each other she fled New York I fled
crazy La uh Josh you were in Florida
just a bit before us but because we're
going to talk a bit about Florida and
obviously the election and Newsome and
all of the craziness and impeachment
blah blah blah I think it would be nice
to start with just saying something true
about Florida since everyone's always
lying about Florida Carol what is true
about Florida I'd say gay
usually you know when I'm talking to you
whatever
um
uh it's amazing here you know one of the
things that I've been thinking about
recently is that Florida Governor
DeSantis passed this amazing School
vouchers bill
um every Floridian parent has eight
thousand dollars to take their kid out
of their local public school and how
many Floridians are not doing it because
the public schools are legitimately good
and because Ron DeSantis is the governor
they have so much faith in what their
kid won't be learning in the schools
they know the kid's not going to be
subjected to gender ideology or
inappropriate sexual topics and they
trust the public schools because of
Governor Ron DeSantis it's kind of
fascinating
it's like America but not completely
insane very weird Josh say something
true about the free state of Florida
Dave I I've lived eight or nine
different cities I moved to Florida most
immediately from Denver Colorado I was
in Texas for four years before that
Chicago before that I mean I could go on
and on and on Florida is the best place
I've ever lived and it's not even close
I mean I I pray that I will never have
to leave I I want to die a Floridian I
mean I mean I have every intention of
doing that unless something inexplicable
happens I mean life here is just really
really good and you know I don't
necessarily say that to impugn any other
states again many of which I have lived
and I happen to like living in Texas a
lot but I mean Day-Day life here is just
wonderful I mean like the weather the
the tax burden I mean life rocks I mean
Florida Florida rocks I mean I I you're
probably the last person dating the
entire universe that I have to say that
to you are the definition of Florida man
at least now in the year 2023 but it's
really really good and obviously it's
been disheartening to see these woefully
disingenuous hack attacks on the State
of Florida over the past year or so you
know up until the really up until like
March or April this year I thought
everyone on the right loved Florida I
mean like this was the model and then
you know something changes but really on
the ground here Dave nothing has changed
it's the exact same amazing Florida that
it was one year ago two years ago and
God bless you know me you and Carol are
all reaping the benefits of it well
that's really why I wanted to have you
guys on the show this week and you gave
me a great segue Josh to everything that
we're doing today so we're going to talk
a bit about Newsome who clearly they are
just they're ramping it up they're
ramping it up and it looks like somehow
he's gonna sneak his way in we're going
to talk about this this really crazy
Trump Megyn Kelly interview and major
major kudos to my friend Megan Kelly on
that who just did a really wonderful job
and then we'll talk a little bit about
the Biden impeachment inquiry and if any
of this is going to make any sense
because obviously it's not he's not
going to actually be impeached but does
just shining some light on this stuff
actually accomplish anything so let's
start though with truly
truly the man that I despise most on
planet Earth I believe him to be a
lizard person not a human being and yes
you all know I'm talking about Gavin
Newsom uh here he is uh being asked
whether Biden is going to run again the
fact that they bring him in to ask him
this question already gives you the
answer
President Biden doesn't run why
shouldn't we consider you a likelihood I
think the vice president is naturally
the one lined up and the filing
deadlines are quickly coming to pass and
I think we need to move past this notion
that he's not going to run President
Biden is going to run uh and looking
forward to getting him reelected I think
there's been so much wallowing uh in the
last few months and henrying in this
respect but we're gearing up for the
campaign we're looking forward to it I
under you know but
you hear these calls privately what do
you tell these donors who are wallowing
it uh time to move on let's go and am I
supposed to interpret that comment about
the vice president that if for some
reason the president chose not to run at
this point everybody rallies around her
it's the Biden Harris Administration
that's maybe a more fashion yeah
Carol the fact that he is so
emphatically saying that Biden is going
to run and that you know in essence
Kamala will be the VP and everything
else to me that is the absolute proof
that that is not what's going to happen
I I do not believe a word this man says
clearly coach to say this like somebody
called him and was like stop challenging
Republican presidential candidates to
debates you're not the nominee get off
the stage because I think it will be
Biden and Kamala and if it's not Biden
it is Kamala there's no way the
Democrats move a black woman off the
stage absolutely not going to happen
could it be Kamala Newsome maybe
um but it I have placed many bets that
it will not be Gavin Newsom um I you
know the thing is incumbents are really
hard to beat even if they are 150 years
old
um I think that you know part of the
conversation around Trump's poll numbers
for example is that he wants to be
perceived as an incumbent he's like I
was President I deserve this second shot
at at this nomination but the truth is
that he does not have Joe Biden's
numbers in fact you know to paraphrase
an old Chris Rock joke if Joe Biden woke
up with Donald Trump's numbers he'd
throw himself out the window
the numbers are for Joel Biden fairly
strong and I just do not see them
removing him and I definitely don't see
them removing Kamala Harris
so Josh I I personally feel look I just
put nothing past the Democrats that's
the thing like I Carol you're probably
not wrong right like conventionally like
they are they going to really get rid of
him but the thing is he could just break
a hip or or whatever else might happen
but Josh to me it's like I just don't
put anything past these people including
figuring out a way to push out the first
black female VP like I just think they
are that twisted
so the Washington Post your point Dave
did run a piece I think it was earlier
this week might have been last week just
pointing out the Myriad ways in which
Kamala Harris is about as popular with
the American people as venereal disease
I mean she is just woefully unpopular
and you know and Joe Biden is not
particularly popular himself Kamala is
even less popular than he is look I mean
I have no doubt that a lot of regime
approved media types The Washington Post
CNN the New York Times a lot of kind of
Democratic party ruling class Michelle
Goldberg has written numerous Biden
skeptical Columns of the New York Times
David Ignatius at the Washington Post
just this week had it had an explicit
call saying Biden you know get off the
ticket do not run for re-election here
but to Carol's point you know the
infrastructure has already gotten in
place I mean the campaign it's fairly
Bare Bones at this point is definitely
something of a basement campaign but
they had this big ad that went out this
economics ad that launched I guess was
last Thursday on the night of the NFL
season opener so the mechanics are in
place now having said that I think that
there were two possible ways that Biden
could actually get off a ticket one is
as you alluded to Dave you know he's
hospitalized and or he dies I mean the
fact is this man is into his 80s his
health is horrible we have no idea what
could possibly happen and no one is
wishing for that outcome obviously but
it it definitely is something that has
to be contemplated the second
possibility it's his twist on the on the
hunter Biden indictment that literally
just dropped yesterday because you know
you and I both know that that Hunter's
not going to jail I mean there's no way
I mean I mean these three counts amount
to a maximum 25 years in prison but what
if Joe Biden actually has to Pardon his
son to make sure that no police
agreement gets thrown out anymore that
he actually will you know avoid an
escape jail time and at that point does
he have to like not run for the election
because the Optics are that are just so
venal so nepotism so bad maybe maybe not
but those are really kind of the only
possibilities that I see I agree with
Carol that Gavin Newsom is probably just
gearing up for 2028 in all likelihood
all right we'll get more to the to the
Biden the Hunter and Joe stuff in just a
sec but Carol do you think it changes
the equation let's say DeSantis really
took off and it was in Trump like partly
it seems to me that the Democrats
calculation is oh it's going to be Trump
we beat him once we beat him again we'll
just repeat the freaking thing but if it
was DeSantis now he's much younger like
it fully to put them both on a stage
together the juxtaposition that would be
so crazy it would be so obvious that
then they would have a bigger problem
right but again the time is running out
so when the first contests begin in
January it's going to be you know uh
Biden's name on the ticket I I just I
cannot see how okay let's say you know
again God forbid Biden dies tomorrow
Kamala becomes president
um I I think that she is the nominee
there's just no other way again I don't
know how they have a nomination process
and come up with anybody other than
Kamala in the short amount of time that
is left I think it's very difficult for
another Republican to jump in right now
there's always a conversation you know
about Glenn young can getting in well
it's it's September I think it's getting
way too late and I just don't see how
the Democrats pull it off to get rid of
Biden and Kamala I apologize in advance
but I'm showing you all one more clip of
Gavin Newsome go but I worry about
democracy I worry about the fetishness
for autocracy that we're seeing not just
from Trump uh but around the world and
notably across this country I've made
the point about DeSantis that I think is
functionally authoritarian
Josh it's it's just incredible the guy
who locked down more than anybody who
was for the mandates a million people
have fled his State high taxes High
regulation he's the very definition of
authoritarian
oh it's DeSantis yeah right I mean it's
all really in stuff obviously right I
mean no state was Freer during the
pandemic than covid-19 or excuse me no
no state was Freer during covid-19 than
the free state of Florida Gavin Newsom
knows this Andrew Cuomo knows this
Donald Trump for that matter knows this
all these people that have been lying
Non-Stop about Rhonda Sanders's record
during covet in Florida they know better
Donald Trump of all people really should
know better because he literally moved
here during covid in part because of tax
reasons but he chose to make this his
home so everyone has been lying up and
down about Rhonda Sanders's record
during covet but more generally speaking
Dave I think kind of the point that
Gavin's really getting on here is if I
had to guess it's probably less about
covet it's probably more about critical
race Theory a new College of Florida and
some of this kind of anti-woke culture
War stuff here is the kind of the point
that I would make on that every every
time the left does anything whatsoever
to try to implement its ideology into
practice whether it is cronius contracts
to contractors to ngos with the Dei
bureaucracies on the campuses the
corporate boardroom indoctrination all
of it anytime they do any of that
everyone just shrugs their shoulders and
says Ah that's kind of just the way it
is when the right dares to lift a single
finger to push back in the other
direction a new College of Florida
what's happening there is a great
example of it you know it's autocratic
it's fascist it's Putin it's Orban it's
Kim Jong-un it's all this stuff I mean
what utter nonsense here I mean these
people are raging scathing Hypocrites
here and we should not be afraid to call
them out on it Carol Gavin Newsom is
about to sign a bill that would
literally allow the state to take a
child away from their parents if the
parents do not affirm and by a firm they
mean not affirm the child's gender and
yet he's calling DeSantis authoritarian
yeah I mean that's what authoritarians
do right I think that people like him
often point the finger at others to say
look look over there it's actually him a
school board in California decided to
pull a book from its curriculum and
because they didn't think it was
appropriate for children it was about
Harvey Milk but it also had some
mentions of him having an underage
relationship with somebody underage I
mean it was just inappropriate for
children whatever you think of you know
Harvey Milk and Gavin knew some scent
made sure that he overrode that school
board and sent a copy of that book to
every household in that District I mean
to me nothing is more authoritarian than
forcing people to to follow the the
things that you want them to believe and
to make sure that your ideology is the
one put in front of parents I think it's
wild that this goes on and it to me the
woke culture that we're experiencing has
totalitarian Roots you know I was born
in the Soviet Union I talk about that a
lot but I I see the same similarities
here where people like Avenue some make
you walk the line and make you say the
words in the exact right way with the
exact you know right words
um in order to fit in and belong
otherwise you're an authoritarian like
yeah like Ron DeSantis right and by the
way on the book front uh you guys
probably saw but the senate had a
hearing on on book bands and John
Kennedy from Louisiana read one of the
books and it's all about anal sex and
oral sex and lube and all this stuff and
you could not play that press conference
you wouldn't be able to play that
hearing on Fox or on NBC or anywhere
else but somehow they want third graders
to see it but speaking of kids in these
weird gender things uh let's flip over
to Megan Kelly's interview with Donald
Trump there's a bunch of clips that are
going viral right now although oddly the
Trump surrogates aren't sharing any of
them makes you wonder but first here
Megan I think this is a fairly softball
question uh what's a male and a female
what's a boy and a girl you have any
idea
can a man become a woman
um
in my opinion
you have a man you have a woman I I
think I think part of it is birth can
the man give birth no no although
they'll come up with something
Josh can a man become a woman
no I'm not sure how many times you want
me to answer that Dave I'm happy to say
it a million times for your audience the
answer there is no hold on Carol can a
man become a woman no and giving birth
has absolutely nothing to do with it
women who can't give birth are still
women all right Josh the fact that he
paused like that that uh and he had to
think about it and then and then yeah
connect it to birth giving birth which
as Carol points out that's actually sort
of irrelevant what is going on here I
mean I thought this was the guy that was
going to destroy the woke
yeah that awkward pause and kind of that
half giggle you very rarely see Donald
Trump kind of equivocate like that I
mean say what you will about the man but
he's generally very sure in his
convictions or at least he's typically
sure about the words that come out of
his mouth at any given moment but he was
terribly unsure of himself there and you
know thinking back I mean back when
Donald Trump ran the Miss Universe
Pageant back in Atlantic City New Jersey
I mean he had transgender contestants
right then and there I mean I mean he
has he's been very friendly in the past
with Caitlyn Jenner I mean he I I kind
of wonder if maybe that's what was going
on there if he didn't want to offend
Caitlyn Jenner I'm not entirely sure to
be honest with you there but this is not
a particularly difficult question to put
a mildly and I would actually go
substantially further than that Dave I
would say that a republican candidate
running for president of the United
running for anything congress senate
running for dog catcher doesn't matter
if you are calling yourself a republican
in the year 2023 and you cannot
definitively say that there are two
Sexes there are two genders there is
male and there is female go home get out
the politics I mean like what are you
doing here so I to me that answer or
lack thereof I should say is actually
singularly disqualifying properly
construed Carol what do you make of the
way that no matter what he does related
to questions like this and we'll do a
couple other videos on this that the
base which which hates the woke stuff
when he does this they just basically
say ah we don't care
it's wild to me because I think that is
such a layup I I think making Kelly is
already getting you know comments on
Twitter for for her unfair questions I'm
sorry can a man become a woman
gotcha it's a gotcha right she really
got him on that
um I was shocked that he couldn't answer
that really quickly and you know I also
grew up in New York I also had trans
friends it doesn't change reality like
it's one thing to say like oh I'll call
somebody whatever pronoun they want it's
another thing to say that a man can
become a woman that he simply cannot
like it just it's fact in reality it's
it this is not an opinion question
um so the fact that Trump stammered on
something so easy it really you know
begs the question like how much more uh
can be uncovered about his beliefs if
people ask him you know deeper questions
I think he gets a lot of questions on
things like January 6th I'd love to know
more about his personal ideology does he
have some and what does he really
believe and where does he think the
country should go outside of not
Prosecuting Donald Trump what else does
he want to see happen in the next few
years it's also bizarre because he could
have just said what we all know to be
true which you're both pointing out
which is no a man can't become a woman
that could be the easy thing right off
the top and then he could say but you
should treat people with respect and I'm
say friends with Caitlyn Jenner and I
believe an adult can live as however
they see it there's so many ways to do
this that would have made sense but that
stammering nothingness and the birth
thing but let's continue because this
next one this was not the sexiest thing
to come out of the interview but I have
a feeling this one had Trump's lawyers
just ripping the hair out of their head
because Megan asked him about this is
related to the federal case that Jack
Smith is bringing Megan asked him about
did he potentially wave around a
classified document to some people that
did not have clearance on that and and
listen to this I did absolutely nothing
wrong okay but let's get to my question
why would you be holding up a newspaper
saying this is still secret I'd have to
be classified if I were president I
would have to look at it well I could
have done you told Brett Bear that that
was a nice place no I also told Brett
Barris I remember I don't know it was a
long time interview will you tell me
what were you wearing I also told Brett
Bear that it wasn't a classified
document what were you waving around in
that meeting because it certainly I'm
not going to talk to you about that
because that's already been I think very
substantiated and there's no problem
with it it hasn't been substantiated
there Jack Smith says let me just tell
you you told Brett let me tell you here
we go again
I'm covered by the presidential records
act I'm allowed to do what I want to do
I'm allowed to have documents the
presidential records Act is civil not
criminal in any way it's civil and I'm
covered by it 100 and this shouldn't
even be a case no and I it should be I'm
trying to combat you criminally I'm
trying to say yes you are but listen
let me just not about the criminal this
should be a case for Biden because he is
not covered by the presidential records
Act all right first off I just want to
say as I've said a million times on this
show I think that all of these cases
going after him are purely politicized
and we only do it to one side and all of
that stuff but in essence he's on audio
saying I'm not supposed to show you this
then he kind of claimed it was a
newspaper but apparently it was these
Iran attack plans and whether he's
allowed to declassify them or not or
show them to people or not it just seems
to me in the midst of all of this you
kinda Josh as a lawyer you kind of don't
go on an interview and and just not be
prepared to answer that honestly
no more talk about it at all I suppose
right I I remember earlier this summer
when that first Jack Smith and Diamond
pertaining to the Mar-A-Lago classified
documents when that came out I was
reading through the fact pattern like we
all were and when we got to this
particular anecdote that Megan's asking
him about here which happened at his
Bedminster New Jersey golf club and he's
literally allegedly kind of
waving around these secretive Pentagon
kind of contingency invaderon bomaran
plant I mean my very first thought was
like is this Peter Griffin in Family Guy
I mean I I I mean well he says doesn't
he say almost verbatim he says I'm not
supposed to show these to you that might
be the exact quote right and to Megan's
point and again to Carol's Point none of
this is unfair these are extraordinarily
legitimate questions for her for her to
ask even if you unclassified it even if
the presidential Records app the Civil
statue not the criminal statute applies
which is a legally debatable proposition
I think he might be right but it doesn't
really matter because even if all of
that is legally correct why why still do
it like why do you have these documents
in the first place I mean none of this
ultimately makes sense there and also
you know from a criminal defense
perspective here I mean how his lawyers
have not gotten him to shut up and stop
talking about this in front of the
cameras is absolutely mind-blowing and
it also shows why many kind of top tier
lawyers frankly Criminal want absolutely
nothing to do with Donald Trump as their
client because he is probably one of the
most horrible clients to manage ever I
mean no one's going to get near him
Carol let's try to give the devil a zoo
here I mean he he does he hasn't ended
up in jail yet he usually beats the raps
he beats impeachments like does he maybe
just know something about all this how
the game is played that we don't know
well it's kind of early to say he beats
um you know these raps um I think a lot
of it is ridiculous I think we all agree
on that I and and none of these really
should be indictments but the fact that
they potentially have him on audio
saying like you shouldn't see this but
here it is
um is a problem and because we could all
kind of Imagine Trump actually doing
that I think in his head he has a you're
for me or against me kind of way of
thinking and we see this among his
supporters also you have to be all in or
all out you can't kind of be nuanced on
Donald Trump and that's why I think he
ends up getting so mad at Megyn Kelly
because in his head he was going into a
friendlier interview because she does
genuinely like him you could tell that
she does she's very warm about him she
she said that you know months and months
and months ago that he is unbeatable in
the primary
um so she said it to me the viral clip
is her talking to me right right so you
know I I think that that's the that's
what's so interesting thing here is and
that's why he gets so angry and why he
says yes you are coming at me criminally
which you know I'm not really sure what
that means but I think that he sees you
know the the liberal media as anti-trump
but that Megan should have been for him
but you need to be able to answer basic
questions and I don't think anything
should excuse that interestingly to that
point my guys are telling me this right
now apparently Trump posted that very
clip on his truth social so he obviously
doesn't think that there's any legal
repercussions for what happened let's
just do one more from the interview
because again Megan I think we're all in
agreement I think anyone looking at this
objectively she was not trying to get
him she was asking basic questions she
asked him about Florida and kovid and
DeSantis watch this
I wasn't I was not a big fan of fauci if
you look at Rhonda sanctimonious he was
this guy said the greatest things I can
give you articles that fauci's great
he's wonderful we love him we don't do
anything without fauci this went on for
months but he didn't listen to fauci he
did a hundred percent look he shut down
I will give you he shut down Florida for
a month oh he shut it down for a lot of
long he shut down the beaches he shut
down the roads he shut down the hospital
he was shutting down everything he also
had long lines of people getting the jab
as he called it let's all go get the jab
the guy tried to change history in
Florida now eventually Florida was open
but guys I I just can't take the line
with it the jab as he called it he's the
one that calls it the jab but but all of
it's just like Endless Lies look we
could play you a million videos of trump
countering himself but I want to play
just 30 seconds because I've played it
on my show many times before so this is
only 30 seconds of it this is Trump
re-election campaign ad and you tell me
who likes fauci president has listened
to what I have said and with the other
said the first and only time that I went
in and said we should do mitigation
strongly the response was yes we'll do
it when He suggests why don't we do this
and I say no that's really not a good
idea from a scientific standpoint he is
never overruled the first and only time
that Dr Burks and I went in and formally
made a recommendation to the president
to actually have a quote shutdown the
president listened to the recommendation
and went to the mitigation
[Music]
look that's only a portion of it and
everyone knows there are all of the
videos of him being very proud of
lockdowns and being upset with Brian
Kemp in Georgia for opening into Santas
for opening and everything else okay
fine we all get it uh Josh is this is
this one look we're all Floridian so is
this one just like too close to home is
that why it's enraging us so much and do
you think it translates like to other
people or just they they just don't care
about the lies because they expect them
well I think the three of us are
probably enraged by this because we're
Floridians and we happen to like our
governor a lot but we're also enraged by
this properly because these are lies and
we should be enraged when people are
lying to us and trying to make us
question the very reality that we have
lived with for the past few years it's
actually very similar Dave to the whole
bionomics jig so Biden and Harris if
they actually do end up being the ticket
they're they're making bionomics the
centerpiece of the re-election strategy
but I did not makes this terrible
bodynamics was a recession last year
40-year high inflation you know a
horrific supply chain crisis becoming a
net energy importer again when Trump had
his becoming an exporter so the whole
thing is upside down that's exactly what
Trump is doing right now when it comes
to covet Donald Trump was the most
vociferous Pro lockdown guy he is still
to this day not apologized and Iota for
operation warp speed for the vaccines
for any of that he is still doubling
down on that the messaging is frankly
just all over the place I mean his his
chaotic kind of frenzy press release in
in late April earlier this year where he
came out and said that Cuomo did a
better job than DeSantis when it came to
covid so I mean what does he actually
believe I mean he's saying basically
everything I have no idea what he even
purports to believe about covid-19 in
the first place but I do know one thing
about covid-19 in particular which is
that there was not a governor in America
who was even close to Ron DeSantis when
it came to handling it and to your point
Dave it's absolutely true I remember
vividly in April 2020 when Brian Kemp
said he was going to make Georgia the
first state to reopen Donald Trump was
furious at Ryan camp and Kemp to his
credit has now come out and said and
saying as much the only question
relevant I think for Republican voters
Dave is does the truth matter right and
we we read that camp tweet on that
because he was not happy about it the
other day actually Carol before I let
you respond DeSantis actually responded
to Trump on Megyn Kelly this is on Steve
dace's show on The Blaze and he said
like what was that was that the
immaculate Commendation that just
happened happen it said Donald Trump
Awards fauci this Commendation so I
thought it was really pathetic to sit
there and listen to that drivel
um it is it is totally false and you
know what people in your business and I
know you've spoken out there's a people
in your business who have their own
shows they know all that's false too uh
we'll see how many of them are willing
to step up to the plate and call a spade
a spade so what DeSantis is specifically
recognizing there is Megan makes the
point of saying to Trump's face you gave
him a medal of freedom award on the way
out and Trump basically is like I don't
know who gave it to him I don't know how
this happened he didn't sign the award
it was literally the day before he went
out but Carol I wanted to ask you about
the last part there that DeSantis made a
point on which is that when he's saying
people in your business need to call out
the BS more
I'd like to think that that the three of
us are doing a decent job on that but
there is a whole lot of money to be made
and clicks to be had and Views to be
gotten in just endlessly going with
Trump no matter what we all just kind of
know that right yeah absolutely
um yeah I think that uh that that clip
you know the angry Ron DeSantis is my
favorite Ron DeSantis and I I like that
he's getting pissed off because this guy
is really questioning I mean not just
the job that he did during colbit but
everything right and the thing is that I
feel like Trump doesn't have people
around him to say calling you know
understands to sanctimonious is like a
terrible nickname and like you sound
dumb when you say it
um and to say during an interview like I
I just I thought that was so lame
um and I it is personal to me like I
know it is to you both also I moved here
during covid because Iran desantis's
leadership
um I remember all of it I've written
cover stories about you know Ron
DeSantis and written cover stories about
Andrew Cuomo
um I covered Florida like top to bottom
and the idea that Florida had remained
locked down or any of that it needs to
be dispelled because truth matters but
also the history of coven matters it
matters a lot to me that because it's
not going to be the last pandemic
probably that we all lived through and
we can't make this same mistakes again
so we need to look at the bright spots
like Florida and like Governor
desantis's leadership and say this is
what we should do in the future and not
what New York did for example killing
you know 30 000 people and doing
everything all wrong I want to float a
theory to you guys that I mentioned on
the show this week which is that we just
don't know what it's like to have decent
leaders anymore so when a decent leader
comes out many of us can't deal with it
we're used to somebody that says says
crazy names and you know destroys people
and lies about everything and gets all
the viral clips and we have the reverse
of that with Ron DeSantis I am
henceforth calling this the Tim Duncan
Theory Tim Duncan was a basketball
player late 90s into the 2000s 15 time
All-Star five-time NBA champion 10 10 or
15 time all NBA team but nobody
remembers him nobody talks to him
because he was so consistently good
forever and there was no flash to it he
retired the same year as Kobe Kobe's
having parties he just announced Tim
just announces he's retiring day there's
something to that I think related to the
way the internet works that when when
DeSantis just does the right thing we're
just like oh he did the right thing so
nobody says anything about it Josh what
do you think of my Tim Duncan Theory
I think it's a good theory I mean like
when is the last time that the United
States has had a highly competent
president I mean Reagan I I mean you
know maybe Bill Clinton I mean at least
for for a brief stint there in the mid
to late 90s during kind of the doc
the.com boom and all that but it's been
a very long time it's been a very long
time since American people have
experienced a steady hand kind of a
national unifying Vision as far as what
as far as presidential leadership there
and you know one thing about the Tim
Duncan Kobe Bryant's analogy I I mean
Donald Trump Kobe Bryant does an analogy
kind of sort of works because they both
got a ton of free media obviously I mean
Donald Trump like Kobe like Michael
Jordan before him was it was it was a
global figure I mean by the time that
Donald Trump went down that gilded
escalator in the summer of 2015 for the
first time his name was already
universally recognized there so the
cameras are already going to go to him
there so you know DeSantis is passing
the most transformative right-wing
agenda in these United States I mean the
legislative session that just finished
in Florida earlier this year Dave the
three of us lived was absolutely Dynamic
I mean I followed this stuff closely I
don't know if I can think of another
state legislative session that passed so
much based awesome stuff I mean for lack
of a better way to describing it across
the entirety of the political social and
cultural Spectrum there but
unfortunately slow and steady sometimes
you know it doesn't necessarily attract
the cameras the way that Kobe Bryant or
perhaps Donald J Trump does Carol would
you like to use a different late 90s NBA
basketball player instead of Tim Duncan
you know I I think that the the moment
obviously people love the show people
love the excitement and if I'm giving
advice to you Dave Rubin it would be to
clip that what Josh just said and run it
across the internet like lib Josh Hammer
loves Bill Clinton and you're gonna get
it
you know that's the path that we should
go on if we're gonna follow this
disastrous everything is a show path um
again it's a free suggestion for you but
it's gonna you know millions of views
coming up I leave that to the people of
the internet to clip it as they see fit
let's just jump into the one other topic
because apparently they're at least
gonna look into impeaching uh Joe Biden
uh that's McCarthy's move right here
even though they obviously don't have
the Senate so the guy's not going to be
impeached okay fine uh but I thought
more interesting than the decision to at
least have this inquiry was the media's
immediate reaction to this thing don't
look at that whatever you do don't look
over there check out this compilation
you know the president has been in
politics for a long time and I think
because he would say he's seen a lot of
malarkey along the way but this might
take the cake this is all smoke and no
fire what a waste of time and money I
don't see any probable cause here uh
there's just no evidence I have not seen
any evidence there's no evidence of any
crime at all no evidence so far the ties
Joe Biden to any of this uh at least
nothing that they have brought forward
and that we have seen have you seen said
evidence
no not a scintilla of evidence there is
not a shred of evidence that President
Joe Biden has engaged in wrongdoing no
business dealings of Hunter Biden's or
any ones was discussed in these
conversations I think they're making
making it up there is not a shred of
evidence that President Joe Biden has
committed an impeachable offense a
substantial majority of Americans
believe something which is not true
there was not a shred of evidence that
President Joe Biden has committed a
crime you gotta have a crime like like
you got to have some accusation you can
make and they don't really have anything
right now I think the impeachment
inquiry is absurd I think that that's
absurd it's ridiculous of course this is
part of the right Wing's misinformation
machine to try to confuse people
distract the story dissemble right now
we're in the distract phase what Hunter
Biden is may or may not have done does
not even come close to the level of
legal drama that's facing the former
president of the United States
smoke Malarkey shred scintilla nothing
nothing nothing nothing I don't know
maybe bank accounts how did he become a
multi-millionaire while as a humble
public servant all these years why was
his crackhead son working at a Ukrainian
Energy company any of does any of this
work for you people but how about some
of that evidence I'm gonna have to read
a little of the evidence for you fine
people this is from the house oversight
and accountability committee uh Devin
Archer alone was aware of at least 20
times in which then vice president spoke
on speakerphone with Hunter Biden's
foreign business associates Democrats
would have Americans believe that these
phone calls were then vice president
where uh with then Vice President Biden
were simply to discuss the weather in
February 24 2014 then Vice President Joe
Biden dined with oligarchs from Russia
and Kazakhstan who funneled millions of
dollars to Hunter Biden and his business
associates in April 2015 then vice
president and Biden dined with Hunter
Biden's foreign business associates
including Ukrainian barisma executive
Vadim poharsky barisma was then being
investigated by a Ukrainian prosecutor
General Victor shoken for corruption in
2015 then Vice President Biden hosted
Hunter Biden and Devin Archer and other
business associates at the official
residence of the vice president the
topic of discussion was filling the top
seat at the United Nations the
kazakhstani government official who
wanted the U.N position attended both
dinners at Cafe Milano with then Vice
President Biden you know we have a ton
more here but let's just let's just come
back to me because I think people
broadly get the point Joe Biden has
repeatedly said he never discussed
business with his son
Carol what kind of father would that
make him at the very least
right a loving father who absolutely
discussed business with his son um what
about the the text from Hunter to his
sister saying I'm not going to make you
give me give me a half your salary like
like pop does
um Hunter never gets asked about any of
this how come none of them get asked
about this there's no evidence because
nobody has looked for any of the
evidence nobody has asked any of the
questions that you know lead to finding
the evidence I think the things that you
have presented are is evidence but if
people need more they can simply ask
questions because I've last heard that
that's what journalists are supposed to
do I get that it's a Democrat so they
don't do it for them but maybe they
should start right Democrat privilege
but Josh if they want evidence wouldn't
the simple thing and it seems like they
have it just be looking at bank accounts
just be looking at Hunter Biden bank
accounts and Joe Biden family bank
accounts and go where did all of this
money come how how is it that Joe Biden
is worth 20 or 30 or more million
dollars how did Hunter Biden with no
skills get this job at this thing on top
of the fact that he's an artist which
the easiest you know quote-unquote
artist the easiest way to money launder
is have a crackhead use a crayon and
then give him a ton of money pardon
my French
yeah no I I mean I as we see all the
time in politics you know there's people
that serve in Washington DC in the swamp
for 30 40 50 plus years in the case of
Joe Biden they somehow managed to get
off of Lee rich off of it you know you
know funny how that works right but part
of the reason why Kevin McCarthy had to
do this is that the Administration has
been shall we say less than forthcoming
when it comes to trying to to suss out
many of the details pertaining to these
overseas dealings that's about one
example of that Carol's own publication
the New York Post it was two or three
weeks ago they reported that the
National Archives has been refusing to
turn over over 5 000 emails that Joe
Biden allegedly was cc'd on or sent
using a pseudonym and you know a house
oversight chair James Comer of Kentucky
had previously already shown that there
was a pseudonym it was kind of a long
email that Joe Biden was sending to
people implicating this Ukrainian stuff
earlier this summer Chuck Grassley who's
not exactly kind of you know a strapping
kind of up and come coming kind of ultra
populous figure the man is literally
turning 90 years old I think like two or
three days actually he's about to turn
90. you know he came forward with with a
lightly redacted FBI Forum fd-1023 that
had allegations of barisma founder
mikola's lochevski talking about the
firing of his corrupt prosecutor Victor
shulkin and the five million dollar
payment to the I mean it all stinks to
high heaven here so at a bare minimum
given the family Administration is kind
of gumming up the works and putting
these various kind of mechanical log
jams in place you kind of have to get
the Apex of your impeachment or subpoena
power to try to figure out what the heck
is going on there so there's plenty
plenty plenty of fire I think at this
point to substantiate that smoke I guess
we'll see how it plays out but Josh Josh
all that said Joe has repeatedly said he
never discussed anything with Hunter
never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses period I did
anything wrong and I didn't realize he
was on the board till after was
after he'd been on the board and at the
same time he has come forward and said
there was a mistake on his part to be on
the board
I don't know what he was doing I know he
was on the board I found out he was on
the board after he was on the board and
that was it the fact is I was unaware of
his Investments until it occurred and
I've never discussed what my son's
business with him because I didn't want
any conflict I don't discuss business
with my son I didn't know that was the
case I've never spoken to myself
I've never discussed my business or
their business my sons or daughters and
I've never discussed them that's of
course just a small portion of these
type of Clips my favorite one is the
first one because he's also this also
implicates his brothers in this and when
he's like I've never discussed business
with my son or my brothers the first
thing you say when you're at a family
thing and then someone well your brother
walks in here how's work how's work so
he but he's just never Carol it's so
bananas that he'll get off scot-free
right because it's like it's just so
obvious right and I mean that all seemed
like evidence to me for all the no
scintilla of evidence that all is
evidence that he is engaged in Shady
dealings with Hunter
um no I I don't I don't see this leading
anywhere either I I mean it's it's tough
being so negative on our whole justice
system but I just don't see them going
after a Democrat as president
um and so I I don't think that
anything's gonna happen here I don't
think Hunter is going to go to prison I
don't think Biden's gonna be impeached I
don't think you know it's kind of a
tough time to believe in a lot of things
and this is definitely one of them what
do you guys think of McCarthy's move
here because I'm with you on that Carol
just from a media perspective and
obviously they don't have the Senate so
he's not going to be impeached to me I
think you can argue it either way like I
think you can argue there's a reason to
Impe to go for the inquiry because it at
least shines a light on this so that
instead of it just being discussed on
shows like this and on Twitter
mainstream media kind of has to cover it
because there's an actual impeachment
increase so that strikes me as good but
I also think you can argue it the other
way which is most people are just going
to think this is ginned up nonsense
because they're so brainwashed and this
will actually get him a sympathy vote
you see they're even going after the old
man what do you think about that Josh
so I support it I do I mean for multiple
reasons one is kind of as we just
discussed I think the Administration has
been genuinely less than forthcoming
when it comes to the house oversight
committee and the various other
mechanisms that House Republicans have
already tried to try to figure out the
extent to which Joe Biden was
knowledgeable about and the extent to
which she was involved in Hunters
overseas dealings the other reason Khan
is putting on my political analyst cap
for a second here is you know as we
discussed earlier in the show we're in
the midst of of a vicious Republican
presidential primary and the party is
going to be less than fully unified I
think when we ultimately emerge from
this whoever the nominee is comes summer
2024 and I do think that shining a
spotlight on the villainous nature of
our political foes the abiding crime
family all about I do think that's
probably going to drum up some sense of
unity among the Republican base and that
is ultimately what I come back to as far
as kind of just the political Optics of
this
I dig it I dig it Carol bring us home
um yeah I'm with Josh I think that
things are uh you know we need to do it
but things are going to be very tough to
proceed from here um I I don't entirely
agree with the
is a serious thing I mean just the word
impeachment
um I I think will resonate with people
and um I'm glad the Republicans are
pursuing it I would have loved to see it
go so I would love to see it go
somewhere that's the only part I have
some doubts about
Carol Josh enjoy your apples and honey
this weekend and if everybody wants to
join us for the post game show you can
comment on Carol's dress and Josh's
jacket and all sorts of stuff join us at
reubenreport.locals.com in just a moment
have a great weekend guys and we'll see
you on Monday
what's that like walking into the great
Senate chamber at 29 years old you know
I walked in when I was 21 and I got
arrested and they just got out of
session I walked in the back all of a
sudden I found myself in the chamber and
I was stunned I walked up sat down the
presiding officer's seat guy grabbed me
by the shoulder said you're under arrest
I came back I came back from South
Africa trying to see Nelson Mandela and
getting arrested for trying to see him
on Robbins Island he was in prison I had
the great honor of meeting him I have a
great honor of being arrested with our
U.N Ambassador on the streets of Soweto
trying to get to see him on Robbins
Island her campaign has come out since
and said no no no you were separated
from other people at the airport but you
did say arrest three times what why I
said arrested I meant I was not able to
I was not able to move
cops Opera counters would not let me go
with them made me stay where I was I
guess I I wasn't arrested I was stopped
I did not live the struggles of Douglas
Tubman King Louis Goodman Cheney
swearner
countless others known and unknown I did
not walk in the shoes of generations of
students who walked these grounds
but I walked other grounds
they think I'm kidding man
seems like yesterday the first time I
got arrested anyway
[Music]